Cowabunga reject Nation we got ourselves
a new trailer for Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles Mutant Mayhem joined with John
Humphreys John herriam I'm great sir
Cowabunga pizza slices all that good
stuff how are you doing good thanks for
asking if you guys haven't seen it yet
uh John and Coy they have reacted to
Batman vs Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
right here on this channel it was just
last week talk about perfect metadata
timing you guys should go ahead and
check that out and while you're at it
why don't you go head over skateboard
over to that like button
all right guys let's see what this
trailer is all about there's a lot of
hype surrounding this film The Turtles
deserve a good movie
[Music]
ah
how sweet
permanent teenager
beautiful arts talk about spider-verse
influence here yeah
into the sewer verse
let's try that again but with ninja
stars why they're really teenagers
exactly like my head just stop talking
you're ruining my concentration you're
fine chill he's gonna die
did you hear that what was that well not
that we can do you guys want to grab
pizza
[Laughter]
yeah it's A Tribe Called Quest splitter
yeah
love that life what was that people
what happened is Donnie bleeding
[Music]
so you were baby turtles who made
contact with mystery goo well we prefer
the term ooze but yeah it's like more
like it's just it's rolls off the tongue
better yeah
[Laughter]
look at that cast
Hells yeah man I stacked what a cast
well after the Kids Choice Awards of
this wide array of talents and many
characters who most wouldn't know of I
expected this trailer to really show off
this massive range of characters but
instead we got one that was a pure
teaser trailer it let us get introduced
to the different animation style it's
mood in the first half kind of surprised
me because it had this almost it was a
sort of Indie dramedy Vibe where you get
a real emphasis on them feeling like
real teenagers their camaraderie they're
innocent yet mischievous ways it feels
like we'd be getting this let's say a
coming-of-age story as it's heart and
soul yet with this pretty badass comic
book spider-verse animation style
influence the fact that they got you
know actual kids to be playing the
Turtles versus getting you know famous
ass celebrities like a Chris Pratt or
some [__] like that to be playing the
turtles they they really got kids and
you you get the strong sense of that of
the the youthful quality of them weirdly
as much as you know the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles are called the teenage
muted Ninja Turtles you don't really get
the vibe of the teenager side too much
other than you know the fun side of them
you know going around the city eating
the pizza and all that [__] that they do
this really felt like ah they're the
actual kids growing up this feels like a
coming-of-age story that it's gonna be
animation style that is teased here in
the trailer that lends itself quite
nicely to the turtles uh especially with
the martial arts sequences that you'll
be getting here but John what'd you
think yeah I would agree I think that's
actually a really smart pull that I that
sort of Indie like like one of those
movies about a bunch of kids who are
like have them have each other they have
their camaraderie but they're kind of on
their own in the world and they're sort
of wayward and left to find their own
way and stuff like that and so yeah like
you said I really like that they honed
in on just the chemistry between these
four because it's the Kids Choice Awards
too they had the four of them help
introduce the thing with Seth Rogen I
feel like that's probably a very
important aspect of something like this
is to get a voice cast who can really
bring that jovial sense that they really
are you know characters with this level
of history and so yeah keeping it to
them you get like a brief brief brief
flash of Bebop and Rocksteady in there
and then you get April O'Neil at the
very end and
Ayo had a Beery I'm just really excited
for because she's terrific on the bear
and you know just so to see her come
into this as you know a voice actor as
one of the more prominent voice actors
to be featured in this particular
trailer anyway
um I I think is cool and I think it's
neat that because this is Nick jumping
back in you know they've they've guided
TMNT for a little while now but I think
this may be their first theatrical uh CG
animated release and so you know with
that they are kind of going back to the
origin or they're redefining the origin
for this new chapter in their uh you
know shepherding of these characters and
whatnot what was the TMNT movie oh
goodness another anime that was an
animated theatrical release I saw it in
theaters okay then maybe I'm wrong it's
uh because yeah because I've seen that
and I know that they were behind that as
well
um but yeah I don't know maybe it's a
new kind of approach but either way I
realize they also liked yeah you said
spider-verse and even more so it felt
like it had a kind of I don't know warm
hand-drawn feel uh uh you know the TMNT
comic books even have sort of an off the
cuff style to the art it feels like it
was kind of like stolen out of somebody
or uh it feels like it was kind of you
know like uh ripped out of somebody's
notebook or something like that they
were doodling into and so I like that
it's like very kinetic like a spider
verse but it also feels a lot more sort
of nicked and you know unpristine in a
way that is you know lived in not that
is you know lazy or anything like that I
like their little joke that they had
about Shrek clearly poking fun at the
live action uh Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles film from the Michael Bay yeah
inside of things that those uh which I
didn't hate those movies by any stretch
actually but this feels more like Ninja
Turtles I heard of course that Jackie
Chan's going to be voicing Splinter
Jackie Chan one of my heroes growing up
I think is a perfect addition to be
playing the mentor to the turtles here
and he's done a lot of great Voice work
before they do I just realized right now
because Seth Rogen produces and since
Seth Rogen also on Kung Fu Panda yes as
well so you got Seth Rogen and Jackie
Chan reuniting together and Seth Rogen
is playing another warthog
yeah yeah he's beef up and who's who's
John Cena's Rock Steady yeah okay uh but
is there like the only two extended
characters unless those three Punk dudes
are gonna be mutated into like a Mondo
gecko or something like that because
sometimes I know those characters are
like spliced out of humans so maybe they
will change later I mean yeah you might
be right about that they they have the
character Cynthia utram in it I don't I
don't know who Cynthia utram is but I'm
aware that that is the character uh the
uteroms and it's the race from uh prank
right yeah at the race of Krang and
Krang they their race had the whole
thing that developed the mutagen that
created the turtles I'd imagine that
that is a likelihood of what they could
do I'm looking at the IMDb cast right
now and one thing too that I really
liked as well is you know especially
with capturing Raphael I'm so used to
them really wanting to hone in on
Raphael's uh you know edginess the the
rough side of the tracks version of him
that's something especially in the
nowadays where we like to go with the
darker approach with things and it's
Raphael he's always the darker character
of them all and here they really let
them just be fun in the trailer too
which I thought was kind of refreshing
especially too because TMNT he is doing
like a full Batman yeah
well speaking of Batman they're gonna
have Wingnut being here yeah voiced by a
lady which I'm sure people are gonna
love I don't care sure people are not
gonna have an opinion about that but I'm
excited for Roseburg there's like a
billion Ninja Turtles properties and
adaptations and it'll be fine there's
there's something about this where the
animation style has me especially
excited for the action but yeah this
feels incredibly expressive it is very
spider-verse influence though it's like
spider verse but like with just a Wilder
freehand almost like it almost has a
vaguely it's like scribbles in your
notebook meets an impressionist painting
them oh yeah uh which is which is
beautiful in its own way it's like
beautiful but also pop art you know
which I think is very fitting of this
and and yeah if you're gonna borrow from
spider-verse which is like the new thing
to do even put some boots borrowing from
spider-verse like I think this is a nice
way to at least push that style
even further down at least the drawn
Direction well yeah it has that street
art Vibe yeah which I'm which I really
do like so yeah I'm sure I won't be
watching it going smarter versus my arms
crossed something like that and also if
you're going to take influence from
animated property spider versus the
great things yeah sure and I mean there
have been so many iterations of the
Ninja Turtles that that Vibe I think
would hold it like if they wanted to do
a Multiverse Turtles movie that would be
absolutely within the realm yeah like
might as well alrighty guys well thank
you so much for being here uh be sure to
leave a like subscribe and hey let's end
this with a
and Drew Hayes you're the turtlest
turtle of them all here at the patreon
my dude I feel like you would be the
perfect fifth ninja turtle you got like
the perfect halfway point between like a
Michelangelo because you got a good
party Vibe but you're also a little bit
of a done hello you know Tech you know
how to pick locks and things like that
but you got that dark side too you got
that Raphael brooding in you but I feel
like you also got the leadership uh
streaking you as well Lil Leonardo
little uh Stern but also quality also
compassionate I think you would be uh
the perfect yeah just sort of auxiliary
fifth member Wild Card Turtle character
that's the mutant I want for you so a
slip and fall and some oohs man get
yourself all mutated out and uh yeah
then go start fighting some crime man
survive the crime apocalypse that's what
I want for you all right yeah I like the
sound of that thanks for being here
forever Andrew you'll never leave and I
love that about you
thank you